good day everyone and welcome I'm Jack
Van Horn from the University of Virginia
and I'm very proud to welcome you to
this edition of our 2022-2023
foundations of biomedical data science
seminar Series this lecture series is
supported by uva's integrated
translational Health Institute of
Virginia the UVA brain Institute the
College of Arts and Sciences the school
of data science and through a grants
from the National Institutes of General
Medical Sciences since 2016 the
foundations of biomedical data science
seminar Series has focused on the use of
data science methodologies artificial
intelligence deep learning and
statistical modeling as they pertain to
different themes in the biomedical and
Health Sciences this year's theme is
data science and the public health
consequences of the covid-19 pandemic
where we will enjoy presentations on
Fridays at noon Eastern from leading
thinkers about the issues promise
opportunities and hurdles associated
with understanding the secondary health
effects of the covid-19 pandemic these
include delayed Health checkups and
treatments mental health concerns drug
abuse use and abuse increased obesity in
the law long lingering health effects
associated with the SARS covid-19 virus
indeed our 2022-2023 application cycle
is now open and we encourage Junior
faculty members working in areas such as
infectious diseases epidemiology
clinical medicine population Health as
well as data science machine learning AI
statistics and other relevant domains to
consider applying we believe this is an
exciting and engaging program where we
characterize the secondary health
effects of covid-19 in a unique and
creative way quantifying and
qualitatively
identifying approaches that are new and
lead to multi-disciplinary
collaborations
participants selected for our biomedical
data science Innovation lab program will
leverage these presentations as vital
material for a culminating in-person
Grant project development Workshop to be
held at the lodge at St Edwards Park in
beautiful Seattle Washington in June of
2023. today I'm delighted to welcome our
speaker Dr Herbert sarrow from the
University of Washington he is a 2023
bdsil mentor and Herbert is a professor
in bioengineering at the University of
Washington in Seattle and serves as
director of the NIH Center on biomedical
model reproducibility
originally educated in the UK he wrote
one of the first biomedical simulators
for the PC way back in the 1980s and
made significant contributions to the
early development of metabolic control
analysis in the 1990s he started two
successful companies to develop
simulation software for education to
provide consultancy to the finance
industry in the UK and has received many
awards for excellence in teaching and a
special accommodation from the DARPA
information processing technology office
Herbert's current interests include
encouraging best practices in biomedical
modeling investigating new ways to
create models that are Dependable enough
to be used in clinical settings in
continuing with our 2023-20
uh biomedical data science seminar
series theme Herbert's lecture today is
entitled publishing reproducible and
credible models publishing repeatable
and reproducible computational models is
a vital step
um for the scientific method in
computational biology and one that is
often forgotten in the rush to publish
the pressures of academic life and the
lack of any reward system at
institutions granting agencies and
journals means that publishing
reproducible science is either
non-existent or at best presented in a
form that's an incomplete description so
Herbert is going to talk today about
both the formal and informal techniques
one can use to ensure that our published
work is reproducible as always we are
streaming this lecture live and for
recording via YouTube and if you are
watching on YouTube today thank you so
much for joining us also our specially
selected 2022-2023 biomedical data
science Innovation lab participants and
alumni are encouraged to submit any
questions they have via the chat feature
in their Zoom sessions I'll synthesize
all of these and I'll ask them uh uh
with Herbert on your behalf in the last
10 minutes or so of the lecture and with
that Herbert welcome thank you so much
for doing this and we are really looking
forward to hearing from you thanks very
much I'm always happy to talk about the
work we do
um so I got a bit of a cold at the
moment so excuse me my voice is a bit
weird
um but it's the uh what happens when you
live in Seattle in the winter
um so the first thing I want to do
actually rather than you know we mostly
put acknowledgments at the end but I
want to put on the front
um so the work I'm going to describe is
I mean we I work within a community and
I'm a big Community I'm a big fan of
communities and a lot of people are
involved in the work that I'm going to
describe uh and it's interesting that a
lot of the work has been driven by
younger scientists um and this younger
scientists would see the advantages of
promoting open science and science is
often a generational thing you know it
takes a generation for things to change
and hopefully you know the new
generation will come up and
um push the idea that science should be
open and reproducible and of course
credible okay so let me start off with a
completely different topic uh this is
one of my pet topics uh Euclid's
elements
some of you may have heard of that it's
a foundational book on on plane geometry
it's 2 300 years of reproducibility so
these are some of the the car I'm a bit
of a collector and these are some of the
copies I have so there's a Greek Edition
1571
um and from Strasbourg and then uh Isaac
Barrow in Latin 167 for eight and then a
new one from Donna Densmore uh here in
the United States in English in 2013.
um the point I want to make is that I
can reproduce Euclid's proofs even today
after 2 300 years
um
if you try to do that with work
published last month
you will find at least in the systems
biology community that you can only
reproduce half of them
and that's a good number in most other
fields the reproducibility level is
probably close to zero
um Planet Of Interest I show you the
picture of the two the one on the top is
the Barrow they they're really cute
little books they used to make
um in the sick in this uh 16th century
um we've got a pocket size but anyway
um just to show you they can go back
even further than 1571 this is the uh
Stefanos Greek 888 A.D copy this is
actually the oldest extant copy of
Euclid uh written in Constantinople and
it survived uh the ups and downs of
civilization I mean I think a couple of
civilizations Rose and fell while this
book existed
um so it's always a big surprise when I
hear that you know material that was
published last month has only survived
about a day
but anyway so that's my little soapbox
anyway
um so what I want to talk about today
yeah is is the issue of reproducibility
in modern science
um
I mean it's been talked about for quite
some time now these are two uh oldish
articles now
um one on the on the left was from The
Economist so it's appeared in the
popular literature uh as well as in uh
more formal places like nature and so on
and this stemmed from a study that
somebody did they tried to reproduce
um some cancer-related wet lab work and
found they could only reproduce a
fraction of them and that upset a lot of
people obviously and then it went viral
as they say
and everybody started talking about
reproducibility
um and
it's interesting you know during the
covid uh last couple of years with covid
uh the idea of problems with
reproducibility and then credibility
arose in the in the covid modeling air
uh area because when politicians
I mean policy makers use computational
models to decide on policy and that
policy affects millions of people and it
could you know and we'd talk about life
and death situations here and it could
result in whether you know a large
number of people die or a large number
of people survive
and there are two primary models that we
used
um the one on the uh the left which is
the British model from Imperial College
I was highly criticized back in 2020
both in the popular media but in the
newspapers and uh the more formal uh
scientific uh journals
um those significant criticism of the
way the software was written and that it
seemed to produce different results
every time you ran it which wasn't
apparently due to any stochastic nature
of the model it was a rather strange
problem
um and then the other one was on the on
the right this is from my own University
this was used by the I should say that
the British model was used by the UK
government and the
um the war the University of Washington
was used by the U.S government
um and they both had their issues uh I
would say though that you know is often
the case the issue was overblown a bit
um because actually in hindsight the ma
the model did a reasonable job actually
of predicting uh infections and deaths
surprisingly even if maybe you know the
software was a bit uh
uh a bit suspect but still actually
worked so
um and there are various papers you can
look up uh they go through what they
found and so on um so it's an
interesting exercise
um
in especially when com in computational
models that are of national importance
right
um where where governments rely on them
and big decisions I mean billions and
billions of dollars are still you know
I've moved around depending on the
predictions from these models so
reproducibility is in is has a life and
death
uh aspect to it but of course in our own
academic work we don't deal at that
level but we still should be doing you
know
proper science so our work should be
reproducible even if it doesn't affect
people's lives so much
um so one other thing that I want to say
even with all you know all the
newspapers you know and some journals
saying there's there are problems here
slightly overblown but
um there was a some study done well
actually it's over a year ago now it was
came out as a pre-print where they
looked at
um all the the papers in the various
preprint servers with respect to whether
they uh whether the papers
um gave you access to the data and
models so there's a preprint here that
studied a lot I mean they studied
thousands they went through thousands of
papers and did a study and
so they're looking for basically either
open data or open code
um so they looked at you can see they
looked at four preprint Services the the
original archive on the bio archive Med
archive and and sock archive
um as you can see a huge fraction of
them did not give give you access to the
data or code and the histograms on the
left are all the time they show you the
proportion of papers that that hard code
or did didn't have code so the red
the red bars are bad okay so a lot of
papers just didn't provide uh all the
necessary information
so we're still doing this kind of thing
even today and it's a major cultural
problem actually that we don't um
provide all the information necessary to
reproduce a given study
um now my focus of course my air
particular area is in systems of biology
and the reason why the covet thing came
up was well it was topical at the time
anyway but also it turns out a lot of
some of the technology that we developed
in the systems biology area are now
being used to encode covid models which
is interesting
so there was some you know there's been
some overlap between the fields but my
area of systems biology and we've looked
at for many years actually before even
you know everybody got
um before you know reproducibility hit
the newsstands we've been looking at how
reproducible models were for at least 15
years
because once once we developed the
standard the spml standard which is a
way of exchanging models which I'll I'll
talk about more later
um suddenly There Rose the ability to
have repositories of models and then
once you have repositories of models you
can start doing metadata studies on
those repositories and I know like from
10 15 years ago that
um
you there are as the repositories were
putting models onto the databases they
were having to curate them and so they
were collecting statistics on how
how often they could actually reproduce
a study just from the paper and there
were two repositories one was buyer
models then was PMR done in New Zealand
uh buy models
said that 97 of all models could be
reproduced and the New Zealand groups
had that 100 couldn't be reproduced now
this is anecdotal in the sense that it
was never published but last year uh oh
shoot no you know time flies I I 2021
the buyer models group in Cambridge
actually published a formal study and
that's this is you have to think of this
as 10 years later now and it's now 50 of
published models are not reproducible so
there's been a huge Improvement in the
reproducibility of models and this is
primarily down to the use of standard
exchange formats okay so you have a
formal method for for representing your
models and distributing them in your
papers so this is good news it doesn't
look good news but it actually is good
news because there's a significant
Improvement
um so you might be interested in well
you know why aren't these papers
reproducible what are the issues I mean
they're all very mundane actually and
I've got a selection here there are
hundreds and hundreds of these okay uh I
just got somewhere here for example the
first one on the top left is the HIV
aids one uh there weren't enough they
didn't describe all the parameters uh
the second one is the model is
incomplete you couldn't actually even
run the model another HIV one the no
parameter values the NF Kappa B1 is a
very interesting one uh on the top right
that's a very famous paper in science
um it was one of the first papers to
show oscillations in the uh NF capital B
signaling Network and it turns out you
can't reproduce it at all
so that's irreproducible
then on the bottom which is a funny one
on the bottom left uh Lessons Learned
From quantitative dynamical modeling in
systems biology uh the analysis
procedure wasn't described which I
thought it was an irony given the title
of the paper uh another one parameters
incorrectly annotated I'll come back to
that one in a minute because I'll show
you exactly what happened there next one
irreproducible and then the third one
um this is a famous paper in cell by
Jonathan cars a colleague of mine
um
they did the first one of the first
large wholesale models right in modeling
the entire cell this is a mega plasma
model and the whole thing was written in
in Matlab and
it meant that it was very and it was a
large amount of code it was and it meant
that you really couldn't figure out what
was going on and I have more to say
about that in a minute
let me go back to the um there's
parameters incorrectly annotate okay let
me just summarize this first so these
are the kinds of problems you encounter
very mundane right
um missing data incorrect data results
that are published without models that
happens even now there was a couple last
year that did that uh the models are
only supplied as binary which is really
useless uh the simulation environment is
not available and this happens more and
more of course as the paper gets gets
older and older uh the wrong model
supplied to the paper and then this one
not so often now but back in the 2000s
because people love to have their own
website and they would put their stuff
on their own website and then eventually
their website would go away along with
all their data and and so on and so a
lot of the old papers you can't get the
model anyway because it was on their
personal website which has effectively
disappeared
so so let's go back to that other paper
it's 2011. this is one that uh a
colleague from industry actually sent me
he was very frustrated he said it took
him a week to get this model working it
was a neurophysiological model
I mean a week is pretty short really but
I mean he was probably who knows how
much he was paid and that money was
basically wasted in trying to
essentially in trying to get this model
to work again
um which they did eventually
um and just to look at this more closely
to see what actually went wrong uh
there's a couple of things to note here
um of practice issues one is if you look
on the left hand column play the right
hand column and the second paragraph and
and the first paragraph if you look
closely you'll actually see the model
embedded in the text
so these are differential equations you
look DN by DT and so on so that we don't
recommend that that you actually
describe you actually put the model in
the text itself
um
but you know even if they did right uh
the the my colleague of mine from
industry you couldn't get this working
and he discovered the problem was
that uh the units so this is a neuron
okay so neuron is basically a cylinder
it has a diameter and a radius
and that 25 23 micrometers is actually
the diameter not the radius
and so if you assume it's the radius of
course the volume changes completely and
that affects all the all the reaction
Dynamics
and of course that's why it didn't work
now the other thing was there was an
additional area
uh that wasn't that wasn't included
which was the ends of the cylinder which
they forgot to include
um so anyway it's like hunting for a
needle in Haystack right looking for
where the problem is and it sometimes
can take months depending how big the
model is take months to get this to get
a model working I mean some could argue
well that exercise is good anyway
especially for a graduate student to get
to learn modeling well yes and no but
there's a lot of effort wasted in trying
to get
publish work working again
um now
you know I talked about reproducibility
you know as an important issue but there
are other broader aspects that we should
think about as well so when it comes to
reproducibility we're basically saying
can can I recreate what you did okay
that's an essential aspect of the
scientific method right if you can't do
that you're essentially not doing
science
um transparency I mean can we actually
even understand what you did or maybe I
can you know get the same results but is
there any way I can figure out you know
what you did and I understand it and
that'll get me back to the the
large-scale mycoplasma model and then
the other thing which is really becoming
more and more important and that comes
back to the covet stuff I said at the
beginning well the model is sufficiently
valid enough that you could actually
um use it in a in a real world situation
you know trust it and this gets back to
a more broader idea of credibility right
how credible is your model is there a
way to measure how credible your model
is and I'll talk a little bit that
towards the end that's something we're
really interested in at the moment is
whether how can you assess whether a
given model is credible and there are
all sorts of metrics you can throw you
can think of to measure the credibility
of a model and then this goes back to
the the the the acronym fare which some
of you may be familiar with this came
out of the UK I believe
um is now promoted by the NIH this is uh
uh findable accessible interoperable and
reusable all right these are the these
are the things we would like your data
to be to have the properties
uh we'd like you to have and uh
unfortunately most published research is
not not under the fair umbrella there's
usually one or more of these things that
are not uh not there
um okay but then the question is you
know does it really matter okay you know
how much does it really matter I mean
you could argue you know a lot of
studies
come and go and they're really cited and
how important is it that we put the
effort into making sure our work is
recitable
um I mean I think it should be obvious I
hopefully it is obvious I got a cloud up
there saying I hope you think that this
is obvious but that for nationally
important issues right such as pandemics
climate change economics etc those
models should be reproducible uh and
credible of course since policy
decisions are often made based on models
today right and and with AI and machine
learning becoming more and more you know
prevalent that's going to become even
more important because
AI models we have no idea what they're
doing
um there's zero transparency
and
it's even more critical that those
models are are tested thoroughly
um but what are other other concerns you
know that are maybe not of national
importance but you know that concern us
well first of all there's a loss of
intellectual capital
uh which is a waste of tax funds and we
know we always complain about writing
grants and there's not enough money and
so on well
maybe maybe we shouldn't be writing
stuff that's that can't be reproduced
and takes people effort then to to
reproduce it and that costs actual tax
dollars
uh uh there's also the element of
professionalism we are professional body
I mean you know we pay the salary so
there's a some element of lack of
professionalism
um
there's also the it's a poor application
of the scientific method I mean the
scientific method relies on being able
to reproduce another P another person's
work because we do that in order to gain
confidence
that a given result is uh likely to be
correct all right
um so but for me actually probably the
worst thing that could happen I mean is
happening to some degree is the loss of
trust by the General Public
um we see that all the time now uh for
climate change Evolution and of course
the covet thing was you know there was a
lot of mistrust by the general
population
and the minute you lose the trust of the
general public I think you're lost
um
it's and it's very hard to get back
probably so
you know even if you don't care about
the other three uh the loss of General
the loss of trust by the general public
would be devastating
um to our society so
for that reason alone we should be
concerned about uh that our work is
reproducible
to everybody
um so the question then is okay it does
happen unfortunately the question is why
does it happen well it's pretty easy
really uh our incentive system is
secured towards less important outputs
that's basically what's happening now
because you know science has become a
professional
um well I guess it has been a
professional
Enterprise for quite some time but these
days even more so especially with the
government pumping in funds into science
that
um incentive systems become skewed and
in particular
um you know a lot of the universities
and review panels you know I've been on
these you see it we tend to reward
quantity of equality because you can
count quality not if you're a brain
counter You Can Count quality
uh quantity sorry quantity but quality
is a much harder thing to assess it
requires expertise
um and so you know review panels and
especially promotion panels and
universities then tend to gravitate
towards uh quantity measurements like
how many papers did they publish
uh in what journals do they publish how
many grants did they get Etc
now these pressures are very very strong
um it's hard to avoid them
um I mean we have limited bandwidth and
as much as we'd love perhaps to do the
right thing we inevitably gravitate
towards these rewards because promotion
means access maybe to better labs
certainly means improved salaries and so
on which if you've got a family that's
important
um so now
yeah so there are there are some issues
then to worry about here
um
as an anecdote I remember hearing years
and years ago uh that members of the
civil service for example a one-time
rewarded with more carpeting in their
offices so as they were promoted they
got better bigger carpeting uh maybe we
should do that maybe maybe that would be
better I don't know
but uh a lot of these things that we we
give our our colleagues like better
sellers promotions Awards better office
space don't always necessarily lead to
better science
um but you say what about the journals
surely they are the ultimate and final
Gatekeepers and we'll make sure all the
work is reproducible
uh yeah you might think that but
unfortunately that doesn't work either
um there's a lack of review reviewer
rigger at the publication stage I see
that all the time
um there's also uh unfortunately a lack
of Interest by many journals maybe I say
most in publishing reproducible work but
not all
um and why is that there's a there's a
couple of well I guess the main reason
today I guess the reason has always been
there but I call this the there's a
pay-to-play model which otherwise known
as Open Access model you can probably
tell I'm not a I'm not a big fan of the
Open Access model for that reason
because it creates
um considerable inequity but anyway it's
a lucrative business and journals are
reluctant as a result to put up any
barriers that make authors pick an
alternative Journal all right and as a
result I've heard this from journals
um no one wants to be the first to
require studies to be reproducible
either all the journals do it at once or
not at all
because the the read the the when the
the time when the first Journal does it
they will immediately probably lose
authors right submissions
excuse me because of the barrier they
put in place now there's an interesting
story though the Journal of
um American Political Science I believe
it is they actually did this on their
own they started to insist that all
papers had to go through a third party
to check whether the work was
reproducible or not this journal
published a lot of econometric
papers so a lot of statistical analysis
on
and they found
that The Prestige of the journal Rose in
fact
um because now people
were trusted
and I'll have something else to say in a
minute about this other aspect that it
turns out that people were then more
likely to cite it because it was more
trustable and so the prestige of the
journal went up so I mean maybe they
shouldn't be so shy in doing this
because they might find their Prestige
going up and because journals are always
looking for ways to increase their
prestige
um so are there any solutions
unfortunately there are the university
reward system is unlikely to change
um it would require a major cultural
shift there's too much money at stake
and it's probably unlikely to happen
um I mean we've over the last five years
we've gone through all sorts of
thoughts and discussions and how we can
encourage reproducibility
um at the end of the day we think the
probability the most effective way is at
the reviewer stage
if we can persuade reviewers to be more
vigilant
um and there's a simple chart we can do
some simple things just at the beginning
right to help matters one is
does the paper clearly point to the
source code used in the study and does
the paper provide the data required for
the analysis preferably the raw data
and and then really important which is
why I got in red do the authors provide
documentation how to run the code and
regenerate the simulation results I mean
you can't sometimes find the code right
they just dump it drop it in GitHub or
somewhere and you've no idea how to run
the thing
so then you have to end up reverse
engineering the code to figure out how
to run it and so providing documentation
is actually crucial
so these are simple things as reviewers
we can do
and you can tell our editors in our
associate editors you know I really
think you should not publish this paper
because this this is missing and it's an
easy thing for the authors to fix
and my experience has been excuse me for
a minute
excuse me sorry gotta go hold it my
experience has been if you do that
authors are very quick
to fix it especially if the paper has
been you know accepted on condition that
you supply you know x y z authors are
very very quick to make to do the to do
the fix so I mean this tells me that
this is not this is not an
um
this is not something that authors are
doing on purpose uh it's it's just you
know the last you know you just want to
get the paper out you've got other
things to do you've got grants to write
etc etc you just push the paper out and
and the reproducibility bit sort of is
sidelined that's what happens it's not
that there's any any you know evil
intent to hide things although it can
happen actually
um so also the very very keen uh to do
it if they're told uh that something is
missing
uh can journals be more active uh yeah I
mean they can but they're not not really
um I mean as I said the reviewers we
need to be more Vigilant and I'm
speaking here to the young young
scientists in the audience uh you're
going to be the ones that are going to
be leading leading the scientific
community in the years to come uh you
can make the change
um there's a lot of resistance in the as
I said in the in the systems biology
Journal which is what we've been
focusing on
for them though are are actually
interested in fact plus can't bio we did
a pretty big pilot study with them a
year or two ago
and there was something published on
that so that they're pretty Keen but
they still they still a little bit
hesitant because you know the minute you
put up barriers you know people's uh
authors will start thinking of going
elsewhere but they're they're aware of
it they'd like to do it and then the
other three are also quite interested as
well
um but there are many journals that are
either indifferent or actively against
it so
pictures which is unfortunate
all right so
um let's switch to a related slightly
relatively related topic here and this
one of terminology
um there's actually a lot of confusion
in the uh literature about what we mean
by reproducible anyway
um
I got this little funny thing from Game
of Thrones uh it's a bit like that uh
there's a couple of papers here I I cite
um one in front here's a
neuroinformatics
um a brief history of a confused
terminology uh but a great paper is
actually a preprint
um by Baba from George Washington
University it's a very nice review
overview of the different terminology
that's used in different domains and she
she comes up with this basically three
large group three large groupings that
use the terminology in a particular way
when it comes to reproducibility
so and it can be quite confusing and
um we basically focus on just two words
they represent two extremes
one is repeatability and one is
reproducibility so repeatability is
where
you've done a you've done a scientific
experiment next day you do it again and
you know the same conditions you get the
same result right you basically repeated
the work you got the same answer and
you're happy maybe you'll do the third
time as well maybe that's basically
reproducibility uh repeatability
that's what most computational science
is actually in the end
uh so some people published a math lab
python whatever code
you grab it you run it on your machine
oh look I get the same answer all right
it's not a very strong statement because
you're also repeating the any bugs that
were in the original code as well
so repeatability is really for the
original author to make sure that the
results they're getting are consistent
the other
um
kind of The Other Extreme I guess is a
reproducibility
which is where now you read the paper
and you actually uh from scratch you
redo one or more elements of the study
that could mean you collect the data
again yourself you reanalyze the data
yourself you rewrite the software you
compile the existing code on a different
compiler or you use it a completely
different operating system or you use a
similar a different algorithm but
similar to the original algorithm all
these things right stress testing the
original the original study to make sure
that the results the original original
authors got is actually
reproducible so that's what we mean by
reproducibility and we keep it to just
two words I mean some some people have
all these different words to represent
all different kinds of reproducibility
but we just stick with these two
repeatability and reproducibility to
keep things simple
now an example of repeatability a
repeatable
repeatability study uh is by plugging
mine Titus Brown from Michigan State
University in 2012 it's getting old now
I guess but he was one of the first to
show
genomics domain
um where you know people do
um teen analyzes on the data you know
lots of statistical work and so on and
massaging the I would say massaging but
uh cleaning the data and making sure the
data is okay
um
inherently practical to reproduce
because there are so many stages in in
the in the process so Titus Brown and
his colleagues they published this
little pre-print uh on an example of
what you could do
if you wanted to publish a paper like
that and they basically containerized
the entire thing in a I don't know if it
was a document I'm not sure if Docker
was around then but it was it was a
container where everything that you
needed to run the study was in this
container and you could just run this
container it's basically a virtual
machine you could run this anywhere than
you wanted and you'd get the exactly the
same result so this is an example of a
of a repeatable study that was done
which is quite nice so he gives a couple
of things here like they had a tutorial
they had a git repository nowadays you'd
put it on GitHub I guess
um instructions uh an IPython notebook
right so they were using these sort of
notebooks back then before they became
popular uh he has a pipeline to run the
data processing as well as the uh
assembly all right so that was an
example
now you might think some of you may be
familiar with workflows you may be
familiar with some of these workflow
engines like Galaxy Taverna Pegasus and
so on
um
they were originally designed in the
hope it would solve this problem of
describing a complex analysis of data so
that you've got to hand over to someone
else and they can just do the same thing
and to some extent it worked but to
another extent it didn't hasn't worked
very well at all a couple of problems
one is a lot of these um
uh engines they use their own
proprietary formats
um and so you're stuck with that engine
if that that engine dies for some reason
like you know it's no longer funded and
the source code and you know the engine
is longer maintained you can't run your
workflow anymore and you can't move it
to another more modern workflow engine
because they're using their own
particular language because each of
these three use a different way of
describing a workflow so workflow is
just a way of saying you know you start
with some data or you're starting with a
database and it tells you how to pull
this stuff from the database do this
analysis then do this then do this then
do this and each time it's telling you
which application you should run in
order to process the data
um it turns out to be very fragile as
well and fragile in the sense that
um
you may be given a workflow but the app
what are the applications that you used
is either no longer available or it's
been upgraded to such an extent that it
can no longer be run within that
workflow and this happens a lot
uh there's a workflow sort of repository
at myexperiments.org many of them there
can no longer run
those are dependency errors uh all the
workflow engines no longer available or
compatible or whatever and in fact
there's even a term that describes this
it's called workflow decay
so a lot of many people may advocate
workflows for reproducible work I don't
recommend it
um
I mean it's a tough one
um you'd have to make sure you include
everything
um
in some kind of containerized uh
platform
um so
uh okay so the other thing is okay
unless we don't have a workflow but we
just have code I could just distribute
the code surely you know
um I could you know distribute my model
and whatever I've used Matlab python C C
plus plus whatever you could it sort of
works for small models but it most
definitely doesn't work for big models
uh so this is the macoplasma model I
mentioned before
um but Jonathan cards about 150 000
lines of MacBook Matlab code and 2000
lines of pearl uh the data is stored in
binary files
um so there's a workshop in 2015 that
tried to reproduce the model but it's
unsuccessful
it was very hard to try to recreate the
model in another language mainly because
as you read the Matlab you're relying on
comments to tell you what you know each
step does and it's sometimes the
comments are out of sync with the code
like the code had been modified but the
comments hadn't been updated so it
turned out to be incredibly difficult to
reproduce so the lesson here was this is
not the way to do it
and unfortunately people are still doing
it this way
um
for large models it's it's fatal
um it's basically unusable because it's
just one large monolithic lump of code
um yeah I mean the problem was hard to
understand how to understand how they
how they built what assumptions of data
were used very hard to reuse in other
projects and and the executable
environment they originally used May no
longer exist and then just really stuck
so
so summary
um just you know just what can we do I
mean the simple things we can do and
these are really simple things we can
all do is when reviewing papers
you can ensure that everything is at
least available available so in
principle it could be run and should be
in a prominent pay place not for example
a cap a figure caption
which can be easily missed
and also check that the authors have
provided uh the instructions
and then for the most sophisticated
you could tell them you know store your
stuff on things like GitHub or better
still as another and obtain a DOI
uh and then provide tests
basically uh
in the Computing industry they're called
um
forgotten the phrase now uh
unit tests with your code to show that
your code can be trusted okay and you
can imagine some sort of it's just a big
thing I put up but you can imagine some
sort of scoring system that a journal
could could do depending on what the
what the authors have done all right
okay let's go on to on a new topic now
and the way we have tackled this problem
in systems biology
one way is to Galvanize the young
because they are
very enthusiastic
and
um this is basically what we did in the
systems biology field
um so in the systems biology field the
kinds of models we're talking about are
mechanistic models all right metabolic
pathways signaling Pathways not AI
models not statistical models okay those
are the kinds of things we're talking
about
um so a little bit of History
um around 98.99 several of us were
frustrials were frustrated that we
couldn't exchange models between
different modeling tools because the
formats were incompatible
um this is particularly a problem
because there's a very high turnover of
academic software
very short lifespan and you can't really
rely you know if your model is if you
use a particular application and you
know five years later and the
application no longer exists for some
reason you're stuck because you probably
saved it in their format and now somehow
you have to convert that format to a new
tool if you can and you're basically
left it often orphan models which is a
big problem so we wanted to get around
that problem as well in fact all the
tools back in 98.99 that we used no
longer exist
all right the source code isn't even
available online anywhere
so that that was our impetus okay
and then in parallel luckily there was a
major uptick in uh interesting systems
biology I mean we were a small little
group then you know systems biology
hadn't really the phrase wasn't really
used back then
um and then suddenly in around about
2000 everybody got interested in it and
there was a lot of funding reappeared in
particular the Japanese erata program
uh wanted to fund some infrastructure
and systems biology and
ourselves and the Japanese group got
together and that resulted in this thing
called the systems biology Market
language which was released in 2001. and
this basically solved the exchange
problem so and to my surprise it really
spread really fast and now pretty much
all tools and systems biology support
this language so I can take I can take a
model from any tool save it in that tool
and load it into another tool and it
doesn't matter if that tool dies one day
and disappears I've got the spml and I
can just load it in the latest and
greatest application
um yeah and the other thing that
happened was to my surprise was it
spawned a whole new community
focused on all sorts of other things
related to modeling such as diagrams how
can we represent diagrams in an
unambiguous way oh now we've got a
standard we can have model repositories
we can start annotating the model the
new anthologies and that led on to
another standard called sedimal well now
we could describe how we how somebody
did the simulation experiment so I'm not
relying on a on a program script but I
have a description of what was done
which can be converted into a
programming script
um and so out of this then performed
this organization called combine uh
which is a really active one
um we have two meetings a year very
Grassroots effort that's the emphasis
that it's this stuff is very Grassroots
Grassroots
bottom up effort not a top down okay all
right I'm going to move on here so we
can uh finish
um yeah what's the point is basically
what I've said having modeling standards
weakness change between different tools
makes models much more likely to be
reproducible they can be now
understandable because you can annotate
all these models with the information
like what assumptions I use where did I
get the information from and so on and
it's all computer readable and it's now
searchable etc etc and it makes it much
easier to reuse the model okay you
cannot reuse them interestingly
uh there's a study it's under review I
know
um from Germany and this is a nice big
fat carrot for all those all those
researchers it turns out that if you use
insistence biology at least if you use
these standards your papers get more
cited more citations
so if there wasn't a greater carrot than
that I don't know
um
and I basically boils down to uh if it's
in a standard format it's easier to
reuse and therefore it's more likely to
be used and therefore the original paper
is more likely to be cited
uh whereas those papers are really hard
to get the model out there's less of a
chance of it being recited so
and part of our Center we wrapped all
this up into a major new portal called
biosimulations
um the infrastructure is in place we're
now filling it up with the models
basically this is a place where you can
go
search for a model uh search for an
article and then it'll give you the
model and then you can run it there and
then to show that to give you get the
same results and then at that point you
could download the model and run it in
your own favorite application and we
support a huge number of Standards a
huge number of modeling approaches
um so we're very excited about this um
so hopefully this year we're you're
curating a whole bunch of models on
biomodels working with a buyer models
team in fact last year we completely
recurated the entire biomodles database
for them to make sure everything was
properly reproducible
uh just then briefly then what next
because this is a work we're trying to
get funded uh now that your model is
reproducible okay what's next well
what's next to me anyway is model
credibility
and I'm part of the iMac the uh or the
MSM the multi-scale modeling Community
meets area in Bethesda
uh this is a multi-agency organization
uh they started thinking about this
um so Jerry Myers is from one of the
authors just from NASA and after the
various accidents they had with the
space shuttles they had they looked deep
deeply into the idea of how making sure
that the models they were using were
credible so they didn't have the same
mistakes they had before uh and then he
teamed up with a bunch of um biomedical
researchers and came up with a sort of a
10 simple rules for credible practice
and so this is sort of the start then of
a an effort now and I was briefly part
of this as well but we'd like to take
this much much further at the moment
this is a list of things that you can
manually check to rate whether how you
know is the paper using credible
practice or not but what we want to do
just go much further now that we've got
all our models stored in computer
readable formats we can do deep dives
into the model
to find out whether there any Mis any
any simple mistakes let me go to the
this slide first uh so we can we want to
split the credibility test into static
tests on Dynamic tests
so static tests of things like um I
think mistakes in the naming
did they use NAD cops or NAD lowercase
in one place and not another in a very
large model such errors are very
difficult to spot right so we want to
create a whole toolbox that lets people
check these sort of mundane problems
um but can be easily
um spotted and fixed uh any problems
with the rate laws
um there's a whole nonsensical processes
right glucose going to sulfur dioxide
that's a bit of extreme example but any
uninitialized stuff uh that can you know
that can be very difficult to spot if
you know colorful uh checking for mass
balance all sorts of checks that we can
come up with these are static chess
tests the models not run
um but then once once you've gone
through the static test you can start
doing Dynamic tests and say well what
are the kind of numeric tests are there
is it are things going to Infinity going
negative doing some strange stuff uh can
we validate is there any validation data
that can be used can we verify the model
in the sense can we run it on a
completely different platform and get
the same result
and the verification thing
um is something we can now do on our
biosimulations platform because we just
ask the you can just ask the platform we
can run this on a completely different
simulator
right and cross your fingers you get the
same answer
and that's a nice verification test so
we'd like to know in the next phase
build build up something to do uh
related to model credibility and so
that's basically where we are
um so I think I'm yeah oh dead dead dead
on time that's amazing 10 seconds to go
um so that's it for now
um and I'm looking forward to any
questions you may have thanks very much
Herbert thank you so much you know as
you were talking
um I was just kind of wondering you sort
of touched on it a little bit yeah what
do you think the role of peer review is
in this process
um a little more deeply you know like
I'm a journal editor I chase reviewers
around hey some most of the time they
decline a review invitation and yet you
know very often it's those same people
who are complaining about the state of
the literature right and you're like you
had your chance yeah which from your
perspective what you know what's the
role there I hear you I yeah I hear you
what you're saying actually
um I know that's why I don't want to be
an editor
um I mean I was once and it's tough job
um
I think the universities have to step in
and say this is part of your service and
formalize it a bit more hmm
and
that that main cut you might then find
it easier to find reviewers
uh I know it's uh you know sort of the
university micromanaging us but if as a
profession we are not doing a
professional job
and somebody higher up may have to step
in and say look by the way you really
should be doing this and the societies
too I mean that's why we have societies
right they're professional societies
they meant to encourage best practices
and good citizenship amongst uh all the
scientists and this is one thing they
could do as well so two things the
societies
and the universities
and the the nice thing about the asking
the universities to make it a service
um part of the work it doesn't involve
money which you could like grants and
things which the universe is don't want
to touch at all
um and it's an easy thing to do right
you know you can say in your you know
promotion packet they could say well how
many papers did you review
um I mean that's
I mean people can game it of course you
know just by doing cursory reviews and
not doing it properly but then the
editors can come back and say or you
know the website can say did you check
the following
I mean that's another way of doing it
but the journals are very reluctant to
do anything like that
um yeah it's it's a challenge and it's a
challenge just to to get people to
review and the reviews that you get are
often not a deep dive and certainly even
if the stuff is available the code I
know yeah the data is available people
aren't necessarily going to go to the
trouble to actually kind of run them all
through so anyway I'm just kind of
curious because you know especially with
things like the various pre-publication
archives you know where peer review
doesn't happen right now you've got a
internet full of these repositories
which which is on the one hand a good
thing on the other thing other hand it's
non-peer-reviewed stuff no one's passed
any sort of credibility test on it uh I
mean I mean Here's a thought I mean with
AI being so sophisticated these days
maybe
we could get a chat review app that just
goes through it goes through and checks
for us
and just right outside yeah maybe it'll
just write the paper for me too and well
it'll do that already now um but it
could write a report automatically write
a report for you it could be your third
reviewer yeah we we offer actually as a
service the center to be uh sorry a
fourth reviewer so if you've got three
reviewers we're the fourth one and all
we do we don't do a technical assessment
we just look at whether the the data's
there the models are there and there's
enough information to at least try to
run the model and then we did that with
plus comp bio worked quite well I think
um
uh uh yeah we did a pilot study with
them and it worked out quite well so
we're hoping to pursue that again uh
with them
um because it doesn't cost anything then
there's no change to the infrastructure
all they have to say is they just have
to have to the editor just has to add a
fourth reviewer basically and we will
always accept the job not like a normal
reviewer so that's nice to know and we
take you know a week or two we pretty
quick turnaround as well we have a
dedicated team that did that does that
um
yeah and we could do the checks for you
but you know in long term I think an AI
solution might be the way up forward
actually
well another thing I was thinking of as
as you were speaking and you started off
with a really fantastic example of
Euclid's elements and you know that it
had survived the rise and fall of
various civilizations had been through
multiple world wars
um you know and yet it has this enormous
staying power and the principles and you
know Concepts that are laid out and that
are just Universal and it's part of math
right it's just what we understand as
foundational math and yet in contrast
the stuff like you were pointing out
that gets you know created last week you
know is already old right yeah I'm just
kind of curious what does it take now to
actually have something that's like a
you know Euclid or Newton or you know
something else that's going to have
they're gonna basically help to
reinforce the Bedrock of Science in
contrast to derivatives
minded yeah you know rush to publish
small sample size kind of stuff
I know I'm still with you on that one
um
yeah uh and it is Data is data science
going to be able to help give us some
ideas I mean we don't think we don't
think deeply anymore I don't think we
some people do of course but
the the the the pressures of funding and
short-termism means we don't have time
to think too deeply about things and
everything is very incremental
and I I
mean I I I really don't like the way
things are done today like that I mean
well I grew up uh you know in the time
the early 80s when I was a PhD student
at postdoc and my advisors were from a
time where that didn't happen and my my
one of my advisors in Edinburgh he would
take two days to review a paper
and that that's all he did for two days
yeah and uh he would actually contact
the authors actually if you had a
problem
then that never happens now I don't
think uh yeah it used to be that there
was a it was a
uh I don't know there was some honor in
it right it was a noble oh yes yes and I
remember a colleague of mine even you
know not not long ago would sign his
reviews because he felt that it was
important that the authors knew who was
evaluating the work and he felt it was
important to sign them and that was kind
of considered controversial you know I
could you know but then you also think
about things like you know the Royal
Society for example and how you know
giving you know demonstrations of the
science in front of people instead of
just taking your word for it in the
printing page yeah anyway it's it's a
different time and I'm just kind of
curious about the the ephemeral kind of
you know digital technology that is like
you said you know things change and all
of a sudden you can't use it anymore and
it goes away well I should say I mean
the spml stuff that we did I can still
run models that were published almost 20
years ago
um because they're in spml
um
I know NSF had this thing I think at one
time uh that your stuff should be
available for at least 10 years
after you publish I don't know if they
do that anymore but if you dis and if
you if you separate the the description
from the execution right
and that this kind of thing will work
because now you have the description in
a formal way you can convert it to
anything that comes up in the future
yeah I mean the latest thing is now
Julia right so now there are now there's
software that can run models from 20
years ago in Julia
I mean it's an interesting phenomenon
too though about like the software you
know of of the month right at the moment
it's all python yeah I I've seen this
movie before right uh you know the next
you know I don't know in the future
it'll be Julia and every oh yeah we
don't use Python anything exactly and
you're like but I went all in on that
yes right oh yeah so so for us the
separation of description from execution
is really important to us because that
you decouple it from dependencies on the
flavor of the months
so yeah I think that that's probably
very important to make sure that you're
not platform or software model dependent
that things you know they they transcend
the computer language the code was
written in and I suppose that you know
for Euclid that's probably true if
Euclid would have written everything in
Python we would have forgotten it
I could never know about it but if you
chose to write it in in Greek I guess
yeah yeah Greek well even that was a
problem because then you need to
translate those
and we have it ended up in in in in the
Arab world it was translated to Arabic
and then it had to be translated as
Latin and then from Latin to English so
um you know yeah so given that everyone
is kind of overwhelmed with writing and
doing and yeah and reviewing and
everything is there room for some
combination of an automated approach and
a human in the loop kind of approach to
review articles and and Science and and
free up time so that people can do more
deep thinking
is there an AI assisted review yeah I
think definitely I mean thinking about
you know at least for checking
certain aspects of the paper you know
that an AI could be useful you know
technical aspects not not the scientific
side but the technical aspects like have
they provided sufficient supplementary
information I'm sure you could train an
AI to do that I know that the journal I
and the editor for we have plagiarism
detection which is all right there you
go oh there you go yeah it's basically
you can extend that to checking and that
would that would relieve a lot of
pressure but in terms of short-termism
the funding mechanism has to change
we're too obsessed with incremental and
also now more applied work and I think
we're losing out on fundamental work and
the next big discoveries that will come
about I mean Christopher arose because
somebody thought oh look at those
repeats in E coli I wonder what that's
for
I mean would that be funded today I
don't know
yeah it's um yeah again I the way in
which the system is structured to think
about how to fund research is often
um you know has a Event Horizon somebody
was explaining the other day that oh
yeah we get grants and five-year
intervals but the NIH tends to think in
about three-year intervals and then
there's turnover within the NIH as well
and so things kind of get forgotten and
everyone wants to create the new and we
forget about these things at any rate
it's um these are really interesting in
reproducibility credibility are vital
um and
Herbert I want to thank you so much for
spending uh your time with us this
morning and uh I've been fun I got a
chance I got a chance to show my Euclid
books yeah that's awesome and uh thank
you so much and uh everyone uh thank you
for joining us and uh we'll look forward
to chatting with you uh uh with everyone
again next week thanks again Herbert bye
now